menschen sind soziale lebewesen die ist
in den letzten tagen oder wochen sicher
aufgefallen längere zeit zu hause
bleiben zu müssen ist langweilig und
kann dich an deine grenzen bringen
hier kommen ein paar tipps wie du deine
mentale und körperliche gesundheit trotz
quarantäne stärken kannst mach etwas
kreatives malen zeichnen ein instrument
spielen
es gibt viele möglichkeiten schreiben
fotografieren singen und so weiter leg
die routinen zu planen deinen
tagesablauf
egal ob für den sport die hausarbeiten
oder das kochen strukturen können sehr
hilfreich sein
nutze die zeit um etwas neues zu lernen
so hast du das gefühl etwas erreicht zu
haben
lernt deutsch mit dem halo deutsch
schule youtube-kanal probiere ein neues
rezept aus weile an deinen tanz moves
[Musik]
bleib in kontakt mit deinen freunden und
seiner familie zum beispiel über
virtuelle treffen
nur weil du zu hause festsitzt bedeutet
das nicht dass du dein soziales umfeld
nicht pflegen kannst du dir selbst macht
sport meditiere ist gesund
nimm dir zeit und mach etwas für sein
wohlbefinden erledige dinge die du zu
hause lange aufgeschoben hast sortiere
deine kleider schneide den rasen oder
repariert das waschbecken
es fühlt sich gut an diese sachen zu
erledigen und von deiner to do liste zu
streichen organisiert eine digitalen
dokumente das ist auch der richtige
zeitpunkt um auf deinem computer ordnung
zu schaffen und deine dateien zu
organisieren beschränkt deinen medien
konsum verfolge die nachrichten und
informiere dich über die neueste
entwicklung aber übertreibt es nicht
immer wieder das gleiche zu lesen kann
nicht deprimieren such im notfall hilfe
wenn es nötig sein sollte
such hilfe von einem anerkannten
psychologen oder coach das ist eine
schwierige zeit
es ist wichtig so gut es geht darauf zu
schauen dass es dir gut geht
ließ
hört zu
sprich nach
freunde treffen
er trifft freunde
er hat freunde getroffen
er hat freunde
fernsehen
sie sieht fern
sie hat ferngesehen
trainieren
er trainiert zu hause
er hat zu hause trainiert
tanzen
sie tanzt
sie hat in der disco getanzt
lesen
er liest ein buch
er hat ein buch gelesen
spielen
sie spielt karten
sie hat karten gespielt
malen
er malt ein
mit
er hat ein bild gemalt
putzen
sie putzt die toilette
sie putzt die toilette sie hat die
toilette geputzt
sie hat die toilette geputzt
kochen
er kocht das essen
er hat das essen gekocht
waschen
sie wäscht die kleider
sie hat die kleider gewaschen
bügeln
er bügelt das hemd
er hat das hemd gebügelt
beobachten
sie beobachtet die nachbarn
sie hat die nachbarn beobachtet sie hat
die nachbarn beobachtet
hören
er hört musik
er hat musik gehört
gießen
ist die blumen sie gießt die blumen
sie hat die blumen gegossen
schlafen
er schläft im bett
[Musik]
er hat im bett geschlafen
was kann man zu hause noch machen um
sich die zeit zu vertreiben
schreibe es in die kommentare
was kann man zu hause noch machen um
sich die zeit zu vertreiben
schreibe es in die kommentare hat dir
das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal hat dir das
video gefallen abonniere unseren kanal